delia Road in what products are offered
as men's and women's that don't really
make sense to offer as gender yeah that
this is funny I've seen men's and
women's toothpastes before a lot of the
hair products are gender marketed like
this is a you you see the men's shampoos
and the onions shampoos and really like
the actual chemicals the product is made
up basically the same way and all of
these different products but the
difference is the fragrances and the
packaging itself it's crazy because with
a lot of these health and beauty
products really what you're paying for
is the packaging and it's that same
packaging that distinguishes the men's
product from the women's product razors
is another one a lot of a lot of women's
razors are pink and men's razors are not
but ultimately you're basically dealing
with the same razors I know some people
would say but David they have the
women's razors that have the sort of
lathering soap around the blades which
is for women who are shaving legs above
ababa it doesn't make a difference we're
talking about razors here and ultimately
we're not talking about products that
need to be drastically different for men
and women and it's it's marketing it's
mostly marketing that you're talking
about when we talk about like the hair
and body products that can understand
you know marketing maybe two women and
two men differently because maybe there
are smells that women like or men like a
little bit more its scent and packaging
but yeah the color thing is always weird
because sometimes I've seen like you
know guns or toolkits that are just pink
yeah and therefore obviously women are
gonna want to buy that right yes of
course women would not want a black gun
no pink gun there's no question about it
another one is nutrition bars are like
meal replacement bars yeah there are
some that are marketed to women
I guess because they have what is it is
that they put more iron in them women
who are of child-rearing age sometimes
are slightly more likely to be anemic
but anybody and I don't know the idea of
like Luna bar is one example that I
think if I recall correctly markets to
women we're talking about a meal
replacement bar here why are these
things gender yeah are those
multivitamins they have like a men's one
and a women's one supposedly there's a
difference like with the male one they
put lycopene in it which is good for
prostate health okay and then the
women's one
I don't know I mean I'm just not I'm
just not sure yeah but I can't imagine
it would be too detrimental if I
mistakenly accidentally not wanting to
of course right took a woman's but it's
not like it has estrogen in it or
something like that that's going to
fundamentally start altering your your
body chemistry or something like that
this isn't seen so much anymore because
there's a lot less advertising done for
cigarettes but there were men's
cigarettes and women's cigarettes right
like the Marlboro Man and the rugged
male cigarette and then these kind of
Slim's I don't remember what kind of
Virginia Slims is that actually a
cigarette like the thinner lighter
cigarettes for you know there it's a
more dainty cigarette often photographed
with a woman smoking it when we're
really talking about smoking tobacco and
it's terrible for you that there's so
many of these I know people in our
audience will come up with them there's
also ones that aren't necessarily
marketed as gendered but society sees
them as gendered like certain drinks
right certain alcoholic drinks were like
oh yeah this is a male drink and that's
more of a girly drink for example I mean
maybe it comes down to taste preferences
though does that oh yeah and I think
that there's a lot of men who don't have
those drinks not because they don't like
them but because they don't want to be
seen a drink that seems feminine in some
ways received as a feminine and
vice-versa where there are women who
would like to have I don't know what
would be what's like a stereotypical
male drink like bourbon on the rocks tea
yeah straight bourbon or something where
women would perfectly uh they'd be
perfectly likely to drink it just based
on taste but they don't want to be seen
as manly in some way I don't that that's
weird and also certain cars right like
for a while I remember that someone I
don't know bunch of friends would always
say the Volkswagen Jetta is a woman's
car and I would say why it's it's a good
practical car I never had one but it
always struck me like that's it that's a
good car I would drive a Volkswagen
Jetta with what's what's the problem
with that all right and that that idea
also might be an body of it I guess yeah
I know send me your thoughts on these a
lot of products are gendered and it just
really doesn't make sense and I'm sure
I'm forgetting a ton of them we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
david pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com
David Pakman show to access the bonus
show instantly